[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 103 of
a weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am mock Mandal and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie work hello Melanie how
you doing today hey Marc I'm great yeah
we're actually in the same place at the
same time which is really nice mazing
awesome so today we're gonna have a
really great conversation with Colt
McAnlis he has a series called
performance atlas talking all about
performance on GCP which is really cool
and then after that we have a really
cool question of the week talking about
differences between sustained and
committed use discounts but before we do
that why don't we have a chat about the
cool things of the week I think that's a
great idea
and I know one of the main things we
definitely were excited about it was the
fact that there is multi region support
for cloud spanner it has finally been
released and it's exciting because you
finally are able to actually scale your
spanner instances out to multiple
regions yeah this is super cool I really
like this one
not only does this mean that you have
lower latency for all of your users but
it means that even if a region happens
to go down you're still safe exactly
that's pretty sweet I really like I love
cloud spanner it's sort of really cool
in that you like oh I would like
something to happen when a user does a
thing in Japan but I needed to be
consistent when somebody in Switzerland
needs to see that and you can which is
pretty sweet yes so the other cool thing
of the week is that Kaggle actually ran
a survey where they wanted to get
information about the people who are
using cackle and the data scientists
that are out there and they got 16,000
responses which is pretty impressive and
they've already done some analysis of
their own and got the data set that's
out there for others to explore some of
the interesting points that they found
were things like the average age of data
scientists which is apparently hovering
around early 30s and I'm just looking at
actually what people are making in
different locations you know the US
versus other countries and of course the
US is showing is a higher salary for
that specific role but yeah I'd highly
recommend checking out and we have links
for the CAG old data set as well as a
podcast that was separately done on our
blog cool actually so I didn't realize
this before they did the survey but they
also released the data set so if you
wanted to play with the cackle data set
on
Cagle then you can Kegel it exactly all
right cool awesome
not confusing at all no that's great all
right fantastic finally would be remiss
if we didn't mention the change in name
for very good reasons so you may be
familiar with container engine Google
container engine we talked about a lot
it is now google kubernetes engine
reason being that it has now been
released that there is now certified
crouppen Eddie's program so that you can
then go oh this provider here it's a
good kubernetes installation so they're
providing all the things that the
certification provides and once you are
certified you are able to use the name
cribben Eddie's in your product since we
are certified yay we're able to now call
ourselves the Google Google kubernetes
engine which I'm gonna mess up all the
time yeah you're totally we're both
probably gonna mess that up but gke now
is officially something that you can
easily tribute to in terms of the name
alright so let's go ahead and get to the
interview let's do that today is a very
exciting day we are joined by one of our
most remarkable of teammates Colt
McAnlis how are you doing today cold I'm
doing good you that's a lot of setup I'm
really afraid of what's coming next no
pressure no pressure at all most
remarkable gosh I guess that the first
questions why are you so remarkable who
are you
nobody actually I'm a toaster repairman
at least that's what I like to tell
people it's funny story so I'll get to
Who I am in a second there's a yeah
there's a legitimate amount of a period
of time when no one really understood
with developer advocates that Google did
and so I would go to conferences and
they'd be like what do you do and I'm
like I'm a toaster repairman and they
bought it like they're like legit and
I'm like yeah yeah it's my job to make
sure all the toasters or networked
properly they're like wow like it's
amazing like sees people's eyes like
that's your job like it's amazing I
don't get that so anyhow sorry google
for you yeah yeah
Google shoo and people think really that
we make shoes no my name is Colt McAnlis
I'm a developer advocate here working on
performance and data compression
focusing dominantly on performance for
the cloud right now how you can write
faster applications cheaper cloud
applications take your existing
architecture tune it make it better make
it faster make it cheaper all that fun
stuff cool so I'm gonna do it in like
the Simpsons way of like you
remember me from previous series as
compressor head about it
yeah yeah yeah so there's there's a
couple ways we can play that game yes so
you may remember me from a series called
compressor head where the point of it
I'm a huge cooking show fan and I know
that you have ever seen good eats
without in brown I find his
cinematography is great I mean like the
fact that that people can sit down and
watch a cooking show and become enamored
with it we tried to figure out how we
can duplicate that at Google with
different things and I thought to myself
what is the driest subject matter we
have data compression and I was like how
do we make data compression and Alton
Brown work together and so we tried to
break down these extremely difficult
statistically defined algorithms that
basically drive the back end of
everything we do on the internet and
make it physical so how do we show data
compression using like sticky notes and
pet dinosaurs and markers and you know
sliding doors and that's kind of where
compressor head came from it's us
defining the basics of data compression
in these physical mediums so yeah it is
a beautiful show you did a great job
Google Studios did an amazing job yeah
they did yes they made me sound credible
yeah and not like I was just rambling
for 30 ticks and they may think they cut
it together really well I was impressed
by that cool but so you knew have now
have a new series called performance
atlas Google Cloud performance Atlas
yeah so the whole point of cloud
performance Atlas is to sort of codify
best practices and and give it out to
you in bite-sized chunks that you can
take back to your engineering team or
just little tidbits that you may not
have gotten access to I mean let's be
honest building a cloud application is
massive there's so many moving parts
it's really difficult for one person to
keep it in your head and if you're using
a platform that's also is massive
there's lots of little nuances and
sometimes performance falls through the
cracks you don't understand how to test
things you don't know the right way to
profile it if you do profile it you
don't know if you're using the right set
of things you might be introducing error
cloud performance Atlas is all about
helping you kind of walk through these
steps for the common best practices and
get back on the page of things so what
does performance mean to you this seems
like a very broad topic right yeah yeah
that great question so I come from a
game developer background where I was
dominantly focus
on GPU performance so how many pixels
can we get through the frame you know
make sure that we're staying at 60
frames a second regardless of resolution
and all that stuff so for me it all
comes down to cycles and operations that
influence your bottom line whatever your
bottom line is so for most cloud
applications you worry about different
things like boot time like if you're a
web server you really worry about how
fast your systems can boot up how fast
the content can get from your servers to
the clients as stage 1 right because if
you increase your web page load time you
lose a billion in revenue like Amazon
said you know last year on the other
side of it once you kind of get that
down you need to start doing the next
step of it which is how can we optimize
our set up so that we can increase our
cost performance so getting the same
result for your end user with less
operations or in a cheaper fashion it's
kind of a double-edged sword right you
want to serve things and compute things
as fast as possible for your users well
at the same time reducing cost as much
as you can with the least amount of
headache for your development team cool
so I was looking at the series right now
and you've published already 19 of those
episodes so far so good
what are those episodes based on what do
you cover in general is it more like
something I don't know yeah already cool
or do you get more into the code oh yeah
so what we basically do is I get a
chance to look at some of the common
problems that developers have on Google
cloud and we get a chance to talk about
the real problems that people are really
having in the trenches right now one of
the things that was my favorite episode
was actually profiling app engine boot
up time just type that in and the number
of people who still have trouble like
finding out how to profile it is is off
the chart so being able to actually sit
down what we typically do is take an
idea like that we sit down and we
actually recreate a benchmark from
scratch so we go in we figure out what
we need to test how we need to test it
how we need the right to test then we
hand it off to some smarter people who
make it look better and then remove all
of the error that we may have inserted
into it we show the a and the B and then
we figure out the right steps forward in
case you find a problem so for that
particular example one issue was that if
you were using Python as in App Engine
standard the particular libraries had a
larger influence on boot-up time so if
you were using sy PI R numpy those took
about 2 X 2 for X as long to initialize
an import than other libraries did and
so individuals who may be doing some
scientific up
we're getting longer boot-up times
during server spikes and ending up with
a massive bill because their instances
went through the roof and the culprit
was really that they were not optimizing
how they were importing Python packages
so being able to sit down show people
how to time that how to break out those
profiles find the culprit and then
optimize your code appropriately was was
a really cool thing to do so how did you
profile it so for that particular
example we were able to get those
packages locally and then in Python you
can actually delay load things so a lot
of people I'm not sure if everyone knows
this but it's import on demand so once
you actually call an import statement
then it's global after that point so we
can basically go through and time
particular just blank functions or no op
functions and see how long they take to
initialize due to the import process and
then you know output all that create a
nice little graph and can look
side-by-side about what's taking the
extra time interesting so the test was
actually basically from the outside
sending a request and waiting to see how
long it takes to actually start yeah
exactly
nice yeah because that's kind of the
environment we're dealing with right I
mean a request comes in you get a new
instance that boots up and we want to
see what the world looks like in that
environment if we move it out of that
environment we run the risk of not
properly testing things in the right way
you know you don't again that's that's
the opposite of introducing error is
creating a false testing environment and
that's not what we want to do cool so
these actually sounds really interesting
and now I'm wondering these are the
common problems how do you know when a
problem is coming that's a really good
question we have an amazing amazing
support staff here at Google if you're a
customer of Google cloud platform and we
have tiers of service we have dedicated
people to help you through your problems
we've got great QA systems we've got
great community managers this is a lot
of information and a lot of common
problems bubble up through this process
so if you can troll through it on a
daily basis you kind of see these common
trends sometimes these are our big
customers right and we get a chance this
is one of the favorite things I like
about our show is that we can't use
names of actual companies so we get a
chance to come up with fake names like
to dorama is an outsource tutoring
system of course ok make sense or Dober
manifesto is a microblogging platform
for animals I'd read that yeah so we get
a chance to have a little bit of fun
with coming up with these names
and personas and how that kind of ties
into these things and if we don't find
really good examples from individuals in
the field and companies having problems
we get a chance to go through and look
at the best practices because I mean
we're all developers we've all been
through the documentation where you find
that one line that's like don't use /m
like why what's gonna happen I don't
know you know so being able to go
through that and write a test and show
the performance characteristics of that
also helps illuminate and shine light on
different areas of our performance you
were mentioning before something that I
thought was really cool because I had no
idea which is you were talking about
cloud storage and how apparently there's
a thing there's one of those one line
piece of documentation that you will
probably miss which is something about
do not upload a lot of files at the same
time that have contiguous or quench will
final names yeah yeah yeah how did you
find this you actually read the docs
yeah I actually read the that's that's
unfortunately one of the things I do on
a regular basis so there's a
little-known system in Google Cloud
Storage that a lot of people run into so
if you've got a system like let's say a
monitor camera or you know you're taking
snapshots of a time series you typically
label the file name with the snapshot of
the time and so you can kind of look at
all your time stamps and and sort them
and figure out where things together
this is very common in scientific
computing very common in capture based
computing and things along those lines
however what we've seen is that
customers who have that scenario often
get throttled when they're uploading
that content to cloud storage and they
don't understand what's going on they
suspect it's a regional bucket problem
versus multi regional the distance is
you know maybe it's in parallel
performance what it actually comes down
to since we found this someone actually
gave it a nice talk at cloud next 17
about it about some of the internals is
that what happens when you upload files
to Google Cloud Storage we internally
will distribute them in parallel based
upon file name so what we do is we use
that as a key to determine how to
separate it out and this is actually
really important because if you're
uploading to folders next to each other
right each folder will then have a
different file name path we know then we
can push those two different shards and
handle the connectivity for the upload
so you get nice speeds when we use this
sort of process however if you have
sequential file names in the same folder
they basically all can
end up getting keyed to the same upload
shard which means that you're basically
bottlenecking yourself into a serial
upload process there and we found this
was common enough that people were
running into it so what we talked with
some of the engineers and we found that
their suggestion was to actually take a
hash of the file name and prepend it to
the actual file name itself not the path
but the file name and then what this
does is it you know given if you use a
pretty evenly distributed hash it
doesn't have to be cryptographically
secure or anything but that'll allow it
to actually get pushed and properly load
balanced across multiple upload shards
for GCS you can actually get the maximum
upload speed you need from there and so
that's kind of the little things right
like some stuff like that you wouldn't
expect you might miss in the
documentation yeah that's the whole
point of cloud performance Atlas is
surfacing those little things that make
big results basically my job is to help
someone get promoted all right we want
somebody walk in and be like I just
quadrupled our upload rate and they're
like you don't worry about say we have a
customer in there like we've hit a
performance problem obviously go to
watch performance Atlas is one solution
step one yes but say hypothetically they
can't find their solution amongst your
amazing amazing content what do you
recommend for like how they would end up
determining like what their issue is or
how they can resolve it or where to take
it from there fantastic question so
first point of all testing should land
in stackdriver as far as monitoring and
performance go stackdriver has a
fantastic suite
if you're running a continuous build
environment you should already have
monitoring setup you should have a
pretty good idea of what your average
peak and alert based processes are
stackdriver can give you all that
information we just in fact rolled out
monitoring and stackdriver for your load
balancer
so you can actually see what requests
are getting cached and whatnot so that
there's a lot of information there and
we have fantastic logging inside of
Google Cloud as well so you can go
through the logs you can see the exact
numbers if those things aren't helping
you point to where a problem is or an
isolation or a unit or a test case
involved with that what I like to do is
start cutting away things right so if I
remove this from the path right if I
remove this from the path that we get
the same response when you start
whittling all these things down you
usually end up with a least common
factor of about two or three things that
are chained together and then from there
you can either do micro benchmarking
depending on where
issue is or you can go into Twitter and
just send me a direct message and I'll
usually look at it for you
cult McKenna's is a service yeah Cole
Michaelis is a service yes and by the
way I mean if you are a service customer
with Google if you're paying for support
hit those people because quite frankly I
get a lot of my ideas from them they are
way smarter than me they see a lot of
these problems on a regular basis and
you know if I can't answer it I'm
probably gonna go ask them so that
actually might be a better path you know
getting support from the people who are
smarter and have way more hair than I do
I'm wondering how often do those episode
up here and what's the plan for the
future what episodes are you thinking
about that you excited about um so we
try to do on a quarterly basis we try to
do one episode a week and that includes
a blog post as well as a video and then
we typically take the last two or three
weeks off of a quarter to kind of prep
for the next one so you know in a year
you should be somewhere in the order of
48 you know 45 to 48 episodes if we're
doing everything correctly the future uh
I mean I think you guys have seen my
table of contents I mean I've got an
idea I mean when you talk about
performance you talk about stuff as
large as Google cloud platform there is
no end to the number of topics we could
talk about so far we talked about
profiling performance for app engine
profiling startup performance for
compute engine for kubernetes for pod
boot time how to profile all of that
we've talked about networking
performance how to make sure that you
can get your 16 gigabits per second
transfer speed for your VMs how to
properly size them we've talked about
our load balancer our caching our CDN
the power of Google's Network like being
able to test all these things our next
series that were about to launch is
cloud storage so we're talking about all
the gotchas and all the performance
things there so things like sequential
upload speed large file segmentation
where I'm really excited to go next is a
couple of things first off is TCP PBR I
don't know if you've heard about this or
seen about this this is one of my
favorite technologies that Google has
put on the radar give us the high level
view Wow okay so super quick yes yes so
super quick is that when TCP was
designed it was designed with a very
specific framework in mind for how the
web or the network should be used and
there were certain difficulties with you
know callbacks and windows and
everything else the web's different now
and the engineers at Google have found
that there's certain mathematical
properties that we can take advantage of
so what TCP bvr does is by changing and
updating some of the transfer protocols
your Linux kernel you can get like a 30
to 50% performance improvement and
that's not just to other VMs that have
tcp PBR that's other systems or other
api's that may just be using regular tcp
so this is kind of like a free boost in
performance when you're doing network
transfer I'm very much talking with
waving hands here because there's a lot
of amazing details and a lot of
brilliant engineers have put a lot of
brilliant time into this so if any of
you are listening I'm really sorry for
everything I got wrong also come talk to
us yes yeah so TCP PBR I tell you since
the next announcement for spanner I'm
really itching to get my hands in
spanner I really want to see how that
performs at a global level I want to
find those edge cases because as people
roll on to it there's always a
teeth-gnashing process you know there's
always this doesn't fit my mental model
and Irie man I really want to get my
hands in their cloud functions is
another great one I really want to see
the performance there figure out how
that's working and one other thing that
I'm really interested in and and I don't
know how valuable this is but I really
want to figure out if we can fix a lot
of the performance problems with hosting
wordpress on GCP like we're already
amazingly fast but are there things that
you can do as a wordpress author that
GCP may give you access to in terms of
performance serving cost DDoS resilience
global availability you know that from a
performance level these are really
important things you know and hosting it
on GCP you kind of get a lot of that for
free so these are these are some of the
ideas beginning of 2018 you'll probably
see some of these things start trickling
up very nice now that you mentioned
performance for WordPress many of our
listeners they not only use Google cloud
platform but they also use also other
providers
do you think that that you're serious
helps understand performance in general
also for the clouds like is this
something that the skills that I'm
learning I can apply them to profiling I
don't know my own machines or whatever
yeah I really hope so
to be honest with you so when we do a
set like before we talked about
networking and the details of like
Google specific we typically have one
episode where we talk about the big
picture
you know like how should you even
profile networking right like if you
upload some data and you time it you
know with iperf like is that a good
number is that a bad number what not
should I be looking at throughput should
I be looking at pings so we typically
have a
episode traditionally the YouTube
comments are like why would you do
something so simple well you know this
is important information yeah and and
then from there we start getting a
little bit deeper into Google level
specifics but we always try to put a
nugget in there that's like hey at the
high level here's how this thing works
and for the videos you'll typically find
those much higher level much more TLDR
and the documents the the articles that
we link with it are a little bit more in
detail you'll actually see source code
there stuff you can copy/paste some
deeper graphs a little bit more
explanation of how some of Google's
stuff internally works so my hope for
the users who may be using other
providers is that they get a sense of
how things are working under the hood
with GCP ya understand some of those
technological changes so so I've been
doing performance stuff for a long time
now way too long unfortunately and one
of the things I always find is that the
crux to performance is understanding how
the system was designed and
understanding how your code is not
utilizing it that way like the more you
tune your code to work exactly like the
system was designed the better
performance are going to get so creating
that mental bridge between those two
states is really critical so now I'm
also intensely curious what's been like
this strangest or the most surprising
performance thing you've come across so
far on GCE I'm gonna cheat I'm gonna
kind of answer you but not answer you so
I won't say that there's the weirdest
thing because you know it's if you
understand how the hardware works it's
just a mental disconnect but I will say
the hardest thing I'll tell you that one
the hardest thing this took me probably
two and a half weeks to figure out and I
had to lean heavily on all of our cloud
da's and at various capacities to figure
this out how do you profile the startup
time of kubernetes containers kubernetes
is known for being really fast to boot
up right you have shared images you've
got prefetching like the hosting of the
image to the instance of the pod and
getting that up like that's taken away
so most people forget about the next
step when you actually have to prop your
containers there is a non-trivial
container boot up time every time an
instance comes up how do you time that
how do you find that number if you have
a bad actor in one of your containers
that can cause serious issues and in
kubernetes you can define for a pod a
set of omit containers which occurs
serially and then all the other
containers just initialize in parallel
and
so you can end up in a situation let's
say you're a company that serves drm
style media so you you're an image
streaming service or a music streaming
service and one of your anit containers
which has to occur before any of the
other things boots up is a drm library
that properly pings and connects with
the services so that you can be
compliant with all the systems that
might have like a two second time you
might be pinging four servers waiting
for someone else but because that sits
in your knit phase it keeps the rest of
your pod from booting this turned out to
be one of the most difficult things that
I could find Kubb CTL is it yeah
Caudle you're right control c - yellow
control i'll go either way on that I
don't have strong feelings ready
princesses only the real way is cue
cuddle it's fine I think I think this is
the new gif gif in the server world the
is it coop cuddle coop control GTL Keefe
okay think of cuddle I like I like if so
like this is in the GCP room this was
actually the hardest thing because coop
CTL will give you node boot time but it
won't give you anything finer grain for
that so I actually had to reach out to
Terry Ryan and Kelsey Hightower and talk
to them about some of the processes
they've been through in trying to boot
these things up and it's all documented
few go to GC PA you'll find how we
actually solve this and some techniques
that you can use to do it yourself but
that took a lot of time to just kind of
dig in and figure out how you know
what's the mentality how does stuff put
together that was definitely the most
difficult and and kind of weird
but you know nothing like you know we
found a ghost or an alligator in the
Google cloud like you know hey I'm not
getting the upload performance oh yeah
there's an alligator over there like
that's not nothing I wish I wish that
would have an interesting that would've
been amazing
Yeah right in fact you know what that's
the weirdest thing there's no didn't
find an alligator oh I see yeah yeah so
for the last question because we're kind
of running out of time but I have one
question we had a meeting the other day
with someone prism art and he mentioned
that it'd be a good idea to ask for
breathing lists from our guests so I was
wondering if you have something to
recommend like I want to learn more of a
performance sure I can go watch
performance at a school club performance
atlas is there some book some article
that you say oh go read this thing
question whoever said that is extremely
smart and really really good-looking has
a lot of hair so I don't know anyone
like that nobody they don't exist on the
Internet
so I got a couple things so first off I
highly recommend that every developer
should check out a fantastic book called
understanding compression written by
Colt McAnlis and Aleks a key amazing
article that will help you understand
data compression at a level that makes
sense so self plug soft plug like beyond
that I really like the SRT book the the
Google site reliability engineer for my
background coming from low-level GPU
programming the concept of a cloud was
both familiar at a scalable level and
completely alien from like a services in
ops perspective so being able to go
backwards to forward through the SRT
book was really helpful for me likewise
there I forget the names offhand there
were a couple good cloud engineering
books that were published in the mid 90s
along with like tcp/ip illustrated in
some of those things that basically just
described the architecture of the
Internet to help you understand things
along the lines of how caching works and
how second-rate providers work and where
your bandwidth comes from and latency
and all that other stuff I forget those
names I'll probably try to find them
will have things that was in the show
notes for sure and if you can't find
those and you can't find in a book form
just go read everything ilya grigorik
has ever written great Ilya Ilya is
Batman so I had the pleasure of working
with Ilya for a number of years on the
chrome team Lilly was always amazing
because you would never see him until
you needed him and then I really wish we
had a solve for this thing and then like
Ilya say like oh by the way here's the
code and then we just disappear off in
the weeds again I think he is Batman
he's Google's Batman we had him for an
episode on HP - that was amazing awesome
it sounds like you plugged everything
but is there anything else that you
might want to add before we wrap up or
something you might want to mention or
comment on or anything so tonight we're
recording this I don't know if this is
revealing behind the scene but recording
this on Talk Like a Pirate Day so yeah
thank you matey's for have me and
tonight we're actually doing perf like a
pirate which is an event we try to do
every year or so where we get an excuse
to get everybody in one room talk like
pirates and talk about performance and
hopefully the videos will be up on
YouTube
soon but we got some great speakers
tonight including myself Jen Tong Asha
hammer Lee Todd Kerpelman all talking
about various parts of cloud performance
statistics tracing all those other great
things really excited about that there's
something a lot of people don't know
about we're starting to trickle it out
but Ray Domeier and I have been working
on a new series content so if you have
seen his pivotal series in the past or
my Android performance patterns or are
notorious zombie video keep an eye on
the Google Cloud YouTube channel is what
I'm saying go subscribe click the button
wait for it it's good it's coming it's
coming it's coming
yes it's gonna be amazing awesome this
is amazing things so much for the time
today does it a bit uh but really
yourself and everything to me I'm gonna
tell you I'm honored to be here like the
GCP podcast is amazing and we hear about
it from everybody so I'm actually
humbled that you all would at least let
me in the room this is like being in the
Royal Palace like so thanks Colt that
was a great interview and we appreciate
the insights and the overview that
you're providing around performance for
GCP so moving on to our question of the
week awesome so we talked about this a
little bit before a couple of different
discounts that are available primarily
for compute engine
those are both sustained and committed
use discounts they're both cool so we
want to make sure that you save as much
money as possible that customers tend to
like that so sustained use discounts is
pretty straight forward if you're using
a virtual machine or virtual machines
and you use them over a period of time
Google will specifically give you a
discount of up to 30% net for instances
that run up to the entire month and
there's there's sort of a sliding scale
on that as well so you really don't have
to do anything which is kind of cool you
just use what you use and the more you
use it the more of a discount we give
you what's nice as well though is if you
or maybe a little less elastic in your
load or you've been doing it for a while
and you know what sort of memory and CPU
that you use over a period of time say a
year or three years which is what we're
talking about you can actually sign up
for a committed use discount so this is
where you're actually saying okay I'm
going to agree that I will use this much
CPU in this much memory over a year two
years or three years and then you can
purchase that upfront
and if you do that you can get up to a
57 percent discount off normal prices in
return for committing to that usage so
depending on is what you're doing you
have a chance to save some money there's
definitely opportunity for that
especially when you have something
consistently being used well great okay
mark we've got to under our belt in
terms of doing intros and outros it's
only a matter of time before we'll
actually do an interview one day one day
one day but before we wrap up today are
you going anywhere doing anything
anything exciting in your life coming up
anything exciting let's sit down and
have a long chat now nothing in terms of
conferences this week I just did Q con
yesterday actually so I am off the
charts for talks this week you've done
for the year or you've got some more
stuff coming up I will not commit to the
fact that I've done for the earthers I
find sometimes the last-minute stuff
comes up what about you really all
that's coming up for me is Meeks
Montreal International Game Summit which
is September I'll be speaking there on
the length of December but otherwise I'm
sitting still for a little while which
is quite nice that's great it's nice to
be in one place for a minute because
it's been a big conference season the
last month how awesome
all right well Melanie thank you very
much for joining me for yet another
podcast it's good to actually be in the
same room mark what difficult and who
see you all next week
you